well ethiopia's prime minister abi ahmed
has been sworn in for a second term
after he and his party secured a seeming
landslide victory in june's elections
he's described the poll as ethiopia's
first attempt at a free and fair vote
the vote though was overshadowed by the
conflict in tigrai where hundreds of
thousands are currently facing famine
meanwhile there are also reports of
heavy fighting in western ethiopia
between rebel groups and security forces
that already displaced thousands of
people just since sunday and news is now
also emerging of a mass kidnapping that
took place last month in the same region
well let's now speak to samuel gatachu
he's an ethiopian-based journalist and
he joins us now from desi that's in
ethiopia's amhara region samuel so abi
now has another five-year term but
that's really not been uncontroversial
well um you know in 2018 the prime
minister was appointed by parliament
this is his first time
being elected
he was he received an overwhelming
support
but it was a very controversial election
with a number of uh states including
tigrid that did not participate as you
know the election that they held a year
ago is what part of what provoked the
conflict that's uh that's been running
for almost a year now
and samuel meanwhile we've been seeing
this real deterioration and security in
a number of regions across the country
for a variety of reasons depending on
the area but how is the government
addressing that does abi actually have
the resources and the political backing
to deal with it
i mean the prime minister seems to have
a wide spread support a uniform like
support in many parts of the country
still
but you know
ethiopia again is an important country
with 110 million people
with an economy that's growing but it's
also dependent on aid it's been having
issues with the u.s government the us
aid which has been supporting uh aid or
humanitarian assistance to some of the
victims that have been coming forward
since the beginning of the conflict uh
according to the u.n uh
more than a hundred more than one
million people are facing famine and
tigra alone the conflicts i'm in amhara
region and desi the conflicts where
we're seeing is overwhelming the need is
uh huge and it's also in afari region
the government will be in a very
challenged position to address some of
the challenges the country is facing and
this conflict is also pushing away uh
some of the foreign investment that have
been important to ethiopia's building a
new image uh moving from an independent
nation to an economy that's respected so
the prime minister will be busy from day
one i would suspect i bet samuel gatatu
then ethiopia based journalist speaking
to us from desi thanks so much samuel